quelque chose non c'est bon en fait je
dis rien bon vous avez choisi higuain
laurito comme coca light et un moment
ils sont mes caleçons
mais comme d'habitude ma chérie sont
rangés avec des chaussettes papa gilles
j'ai bien réfléchi et peux pas je crois
que j'ai pas l'instinct maternel
karine du tout tu es chez toi ah non je
comprends pas qu'est ce qui se voit ma
chérie star avec fils faisait toujours
ensemble maman n'ont toujours pas eh ben
c'est bien pour moi pas tu imagines un
petit 7 enfants héritent de mon cul oui
mieux ou des prix commune kilos depuis
début la grossesse
et on tape un peu grossi toi je suis pas
gros ça je suis enceinte
oh pas grand chose et puis la city 1-6
et la couche de gras qui interfère avec
la sonde
ça se fait je suis plus toute seule à
moi maintenant de faire des choix
d'adulte responsable
je voulais aussi vous parler du risque
de déferlement des poussées
c'est une chose extrêmement naturelle la
pipette laxatives elle s'introduit par
la nuit
tout simplement